half as amer an art activist remembers
the first time he was inspired by
political art it was during the first
interfada in 1987 when palestinians rose
up in mass popular civil disobedience
aimed at ending the occupation
international political pressure faced
by israel convinced it to begin peace
talks with the palestinians which led to
the oslo accords a deal to create a
two-state solution that never
materialized and life under israeli
occupation continues till this day
hafez's art aims to challenge the
israeli narrative and attempts to block
their voices on social media
there's a lot of lies
going around there's a lot of illusion
they're trying to put into people's
heads especially the new generations
those generations that didn't live the
second intifada or didn't see
all the aspects of the occupation our
role as artists as people who can you
know deliver messages is to show them is
to tell them the truth tell them their
history tell them their reality as it is
more than half of the palestinian
population is under the age of 30 and
they've never known anything else other
than living under israeli occupation
they've also never seen this promise
that was made to previous generations by
the oslo accords and that is an
independent state
we look out at a world built on division
and privilege
started an online video campaign called
uncivilized and told you you are
unworthy
it focuses on the nuances of language
when it comes to oppression and human
rights abuses
the concept behind uncivilized is not
just about palestine but it's a global
thing it's about how
there's been double standards and really
a racist approach in the way
brown and black people have been covered
for a very long time just look at the
way palestine is covered by western
media
many palestinian youngsters we spoke to
say the resistance against israeli
occupation is no longer one-dimensional
and has moved beyond only protesting on
the streets
changing the narrative is not going to
liberate palestine on its own but it's
such an important part because it's
about redefining a new reality that
moves us beyond oslo which really
entrenched apartheid and the one state
reality we live under so it's about
defining the future defining what we
want and how we get there and to leave
the past behind
with palestinian youth increasingly
disenfranchised with life under
occupation they're finding their voice
in more ways than one and to challenge
those in power and step they say in
holding israel accountable
al-jazeera ramallah in the occupied west
bank